[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and this is a kind of a weird video
right because not so many times do I
wrote there such a villain that I feel
as a copycat you understand but let's
dig deeper into this today I bring you
none other then sideshows look at
doomsday now before I even go into about
this statute it was a decision that I
had to make there was the prime one
version that looks like this
and then there's this version now the
prom one version is is a larger statue I
actually saw somebody you know they
purchased it as a larger stature but at
the same time the statute didn't depict
doomsday in the manner that I thought
that he needed and I thought there's a
sideshow maquette depicted it perfectly
it shows him being ferocious so let's
rewind this let's go back right I was
reading oh I'm not really a DC fan
really a Marvel dude because I can't
really relate to DC characters that much
because you know most of them are like
mythical like gods and stuff like that
and they need some type of MacGuffin to
destroy them where you know Marvel
characters are more grounded so at this
time I you know we I was getting a comic
book well not of a comic book of a
magazine every month about comic books
and you know they was telling the
upcoming stuff that was gonna happen in
DC gonna rock the world and you know
superheroes was gonna die and was
starting a Superman something like that
so I started collecting Superman books
and as as doomsday was progression it
was like and the panel's it was show
like a fist banging against the wall
banging against a wall like a boom
doorman ever say doomsday is coming and
then the fist broke out and when
doomsday broke out he had like one arm
tied behind his back is he
he was like drop from the ground or
something and he met her with the
Justice Society and all Justice League
of America to beating and he beat the
crap out of them
and I'll never forget that book because
you know Superman steps in and you know
Booster Gold is there and the Axminster
you know what's going on and it's like
doomsday and Superman goes there and
doomsday looks at him sees him there and
punches him and Superman doesn't move
and um then he sidekick Superman through
a barnyard through a wall through
everything and that's when he knew who
he was messing with no not really so
much so but the Superman still always
had this arrogance about him that he's
Superman and what I loved about the book
so much was during this battle with
doomsday and other heroes tried to jump
in and try to save Superman or or try to
defend the earth or the city and during
this battle Superman realized this might
be it
this just this might be then if he
doesn't make a stand now this monster
will go on and there's no superhero
strong enough to beat him and it was
like one killing blow and Jimmy Olsen is
reporting the whole taking the film of
it you know the shooting uh pitches
while Lois Lane is report Lois Lane is
watching the man that she loved died and
then he does die
and unthinkable happens Superman
actually perishes in a battle and she's
holding the body and they made such a
thing out of it now a lot of people try
to get rich they tried to buy a bunch of
those books also meant that what DC did
was they over printed the books and you
can find them in common shops all over
the world I guess you know she but it
didn't take away from danger guns and a
lot of these guys stored in Joker's was
doing the artwork and it didn't take
away from the story that they think and
wrote it was a great story if they put a
lot of interest in DC I think
single-handedly doomsday brought me back
to DC Comics to to read because it
showed that these so-called immortals in
diamond and the fact that doomsday to
meet was like a cheap ripoff of The
Incredible Hulk
which I thought that you know was robbed
and his battle with Superman so that
brings me to this statute that brings me
to why I purchased the statute for the
simple fact that if you know in my
collection I
I actually feel that power should be
celebrated strength should be applauded
and you know aggressive ferocity should
definitely be something to be admired
and that's why I love The Incredible
Hulk so why not have DC's version DC's
knockoff of The Incredible Hulk and all
of his glory see this is where he's
holding the cape that represents a hell
of a lot you know um there's a comic
book cover with him with the torn up
cape this is the reason why I went with
this one besides the fact that this
Aquaman's Trident and the statue
Wonder Woman's sword in the statute
Batman's cowl in the statute and if you
look real closely
[Music]
to his left hand
you'll see he has Green Lantern's ring
on his finger right here
Kota was absolutely amazing I thought
the detail on a statue was insane one
thing I don't like about the statute is
that it has a seam along the neckline
and that's about it
but as to custom has to stretch out
heads as well which is the woman who
broke out of his containment and he had
that one-eyed you know and then he has
the one fully mask off with his hair
flowing the way then I'm gonna depicted
the way that I'm gonna display it and
show it because I believe this shows
this poetry in motion
it shows such strength whereas the other
prime one studio statute just showed
like if you're looking through a Hazen
he had destroyed this that's what it
looked like to me when this one who
looks like he's in a pitchfork battle
and he's actually tearing up the city so
that's why this statue means a lot came
in one big box beautiful art box
he's one whole piece so you know a lot
of people ask me ain't King uh why don't
you go into the dimensions of stuff of
the statute well this is the part of the
video where I'm gonna tell you to like
follow subscribe and go to loads of
gaming dinette where you get a
background synapses of this character
this statue and all the dimensions see I
don't ever tell you to go to log net
loads of Kevin Garnett for just the
great review
and addicts great video game reviews and
I have a lot of opinion pieces from our
tons of writers or you know old episodes
of lords of iron Lords podcast on Kos or
Kombat talk with the king or the last
word with loyal Cognito and he bonta's
know it's not for all that great content
it's also to get more information on the
statute say a lot of times people can
bore you with dimensions and all that
other stuff let me give you why I
purchased the statute I'm gonna give you
my experience and my decision-making and
purchasing the statute because I think
that's important for you to know I want
you to stay collected and when you're
collecting it's like a tattoo
know why understand what does that
statue make you feel when you're
purchasing because these are high ticket
items this one was I think it was $12.99
1200 1300 well worth it
so again
see you next week when I bring you an
incredible statue that is near and dear
to my heart
state collector
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]